non-minimalists
what are your thoughts on the tiny house
movement do you consider this part of
living a minimalist
life of course you can't be a minimalist
unless you live in a tiny house
it has to be a 190 square feet or
smaller
that is what we've determined in our
minimalist rule book available now for
29.95
erica what what is what does the
question isn't about what josh and i
think about the tiny house movement
erica what do you think about the tiny
house movement yeah
yeah does it does it suit your life is
that something that would really add a
lot of value
to your life is it something that would
help out the people you live with maybe
you live by yourself and maybe that's
why it's appealing to you
but you know the tiny house movement it
is it's a tool
that is very it's it's uh i want to say
readily available i mean you can go out
and find a
million different blueprints there are
uh you know a lot of different
contracting companies that are building
tiny houses now i mean it's a tool that
we
have available to us to help us live a
simple life right to help us
uh get a home you know because that's
part of the necessities we have to have
that
yeah so you can get a home maybe it's
not uh you know a thousand square foot
maybe it is only 190 square foot but you
don't have a payment on that home
and you are able to stay warm you've got
a indoor bathroom
so there are these things that we
absolutely need in a tiny house
and uh it helps us to live it can help
us live a more simple life but
man like i mariah and i i mean we're i'm
six foot she's five ten um
dude we we're kind of tall lengthy
people i mean
living in a tiny house sounds it doesn't
sound the most appealing
uh to mariah and i right now but that
doesn't mean that it's not right
for you erica i'm not a fan of the tiny
house movement
i am a fan of the appropriately sized
house
movement and for some people 190 square
feet
is appropriate and then i'm a fan of
that for them
and i'm a fan of allowing people to
pursue what their preferences
are i really think it's nice i like what
our friend
um uh graham hill is doing with the
tiny apartments and uh especially in
cities like new york city
where we he's in our documentary and
they have that 420 square foot apartment
to sleep seven and you can have dinner
for
10 in in the house and and you can have
a movie theater screening of like with
eight people and
all in this 400 square foot place
because it's modular and things come out
of the ceiling and the floor and you've
got a stand-up desk and a cat
you have all of these things where
they're using that space to the best
of their ability and i really like that
because that 400 square feet feels
way bigger because they have some taller
ceilings
it feels way bigger than 400 square feet
now
becks and ella and i live in a place
that is probably 900 square feet
i don't know i don't measure my square
footage but what i know
is it's appropriately sized for us there
are two bedrooms there's a living room
slash dining slash kitchen area
and a couple bathrooms and that's really
it that's what is appropriate
for us however i that wasn't always
appropriate for me i used to live in
a loft apartment because that is what
worked for me when i was
single it was just me by myself let's
just have this this one room
that is appropriate for me so what is
appropriate today
may change tomorrow the living space
that you need right now
might not be the living space that you
need tomorrow i think about the empty
nesters who keep
their you know big five bedroom houses
and all four kids are out of the house
and
all of a sudden they're like well i
guess we'll just hang around here
we've got way too much house and so what
do they try to do they try to cram a
life
into that house because it's all they
know
as opposed to finding a new house that
fits whatever their new lifestyle
is and so regardless of the the square
footage of your house
i would encourage people to not feel
compelled to cram someone else's version
of an ideal life into that square
footage
find the square footage that's right for
you but always be willing to adjust
accordingly yeah man you know even if
you and i were
big fans of tiny houses and let's say we
were like living the tiny house dream
i mean we would not impose that
preference on other people exactly yeah
and if you have a
3 000 square actually i think the
average house being built last year was
4 300 square feet or something
you know what there are plenty of people
who get immense value from something
like that and i'm not one
to judge however if you look at the heat
map study it's in our documentary
on a monthly basis we tend to use about
40 of our of our households on
average so most people aren't going to
get
basically they're not going to use half
the space that they live in right now
and so the way we can fix that is by
having a
more appropriately sized place to live